اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نصطاد ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
مساعد امريكيه لتجنب عدوى
القوات الروسيه تحاول اختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه في باخ متوكييف بصعوبه الوضع
بعد 17 عاما داخل سجن اسرائيلي اكبر
الاسرار الفلسطينيين على موعد مع الحريه
اليوم
يه باطلاق صاروخ كروز
حاله التاهب
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اول تعليق روسي على
ازمه بنكين امريكيين قالت المتحدثه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه
قالت ان الولايات المتحده ستحاول انقاذ
نظامها المصرفي من خلال طباعه النقود
مشيره الى ان عمليه طباعه النقود تؤدي الى
تفاقم الازمه الاقتصاديه حول العالم هذا
واكدت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه كانت ان
الحكومه تريد تجنب تاثير افلاس بنك
سيليكون فالي على بقيه النظام المصرفي
وقالت خلال مقابله مع شبكه سي بي اس
الامريكيه ان الحكومه تريد التاكد من ان
مشكلات احد البنوك لا تسبب عدوى لبنوك
اخرى قويه واشارت الى انه يجري العمل مع
وكاله التامين الودائع لايجاد حل لبنك
السيليكون فالي الذي لا يعطي التامين نحو
96 من ودائعه مؤكده ان وكاله تامين
الودائع تدرس مجموعه واسعه من الحلول بما
في ذلك الاستحواذ من بنك اخر مستبعده في
الوقت ذاته انقاذ البنك عبر ضخ اموال عامه
قبل ذلك مشاهدينا اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن التوصل الى حل في ازمه بن كيس
ريكونفالي حيث طمئن رئيس الامريكي
المودعين بان ودائعهم موجوده ويمكنهم
سحبها عند الحاجه وقال ان الحل الذي تم
التواصل اليه مع مسؤول البنكين يجنب تعريض
اموال دافع الضرائب للخطر كما تعهد بايدن
بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن انهيار بنك سيليكون
فالي مؤكدا التزامه ببذل المزيد من الجهود
لتنظيم ورقابه البنوك الكبرى من جهتها
قالت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ومجلس
الاحتياطي الاتحادي والمؤسسه الاتحاديه
للتامين على الودائع قالوا ان المدعين
يستطيعون الوصول الى كل اموالهم بدءا من
اليوم الاثنين وانا دافع الضرائب لن
يتحملوا اي خسائر لها علاقه بالقرار
المرتبط ببنك السيليكون فالي كما اكد
صندوق النقد الدوري انه يراقب الاثار
المحتمله على الاستقرار المالي بسبب
انهيار بنك السيليكون فالي معبرا
عفوا معبرا عن ثقته في ان واشنطن تتخذ
الاجراءات الملائمه وحول ازمه بنك وادي
السيليكون اكد ريجيستونا كان العمل جاري
لايجاد حلول مناسبه للازمه واضاف ان
بريطانيا ستواصل دعم قطاع تكنولوجيا الذي
يشهد تفوقا عالميا
والانسان
اتفاهم والقلق الذي يخيم على الناس حول ما
يحدث مع بنك سيليكون فالي تحدثت الى بنك
انجلترا والمنظمين لدينا حول ايجاد حل
مناسب سيكون لدى الحكومه المزيد لتقوله عن
هذا الامر اريد طمانه الناس باننا سنواصل
دعم قطاع التكنولوجيا الذي يتفوق على
العالم في الوظائف عاليه المستوى التي
يوفرها
واعلن بنك انجلترا المركزي اتمام استحواذ
بنك اتش اس بي سي على الشق البريطاني لبنك
سيليكون فالي الذي تعرض لانهيار مقابل
جنيه الاسترليني واحد فقط وقال وزير
الخزانه البريطاني فان الصفقه تمت الصبح
اليوم وانه يمكن لعملاء بنك في بريطانيا
الوصول الى ودائعهم ابتداء من اليوم
متعهدا بحمايه اموال المذيعين واكد بنك
انجلترا المركزي ان البنوك الاخرى لم
تتاثر بالازمه وان النظام المصرفيه لا
يزال امنا ومستقرا
كارثه مصرفيه قد تطال البنوك الامريكيه في
حال لم تقدم اداره الرئيس جو بايدن حلا في
اسرع وقت
بدات مع ازمه افلاس بنك سيليكون فالي
والتي تعد الاكبر منذ الازمه الماليه
العالميه عام 2008
ازمه اس في بي ادت الى هلع بين المودعين
في البنك ليتجهوا الى سحب اموالهم دفعه
واحده بينما اصول البنك لا تكفي لتغطيه
جميع الودائع فالمبالغ التي تكون ادنى من
250 الف دولار يغطيها تامين للسحب الفوري
من قبل مؤسسه تامين الوداع الفيدراليه
لتبقى بقيه المبالغ في البنك
ضغط المودعين على سيليكون فالي ادى الى
انهياره ما دفع الحكومه لاغلاقه بجميع
فروعه والاتجاه الى ايجاد حل لانقاذ اموال
المودعين
الخوف الاكبر ان تنتقل العدوى الى بنوك
اخرى مشابهه لسليكون فالي ما قد يؤدي الى
كارثه مصرفيه حقيقيه ونزيف في تمويل قطاع
التكنولوجيا والشركات الناشئه
مصادر من البيت الابيض اكدت ان مسؤول
اداره بايدن يقيمون تداعيات انهيار البنك
تجنبا لتاثير افلاس اس في بي على بقيه
البنوك
يبقى الحل معلقا حتى يوم الاثنين الذي
يجتمع خلاله البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي
ومن دبي مشاهدينا ينضم الينا المحلل
الاقتصادي احمد الخطيب احمد معنا في هذه
النشره لعل اول ما تباد الى الذهن عند
سماع خبر انهيار هذين البنكين الامريكيين
الذهن ما حدث في 2008 عندما انهار بنك
واشنطن هل نحن امام سيناريو مشابه
هلا يعني بعض الظروف مشابهه ولكن يعني
طريقه التعامل مع
المستجدات اللي عم بتصير مع البنوك مختلفه
اسرع القرارات السريعه القرارات كبيره
ومهمه
مشان هيك انا برايي الاداره الامريكيه
بمختلف اجنحتها يعني عم بتحاول تشدد على
طمانه
قطاع المصارف قطاع المذيعين بشكل عام خوفا
من انه يعني فقدان الثقه انه يؤثر على
مشاكل اخرى في ظل انه الاقتصاد الامريكي
بشكل عام عنده الكثير من التحديات من
التضخم وصف الدين واشياء اخرى اعتقد
السيناريو يعني في في شبه ولكن يعني
التعامل معه حتى الان عم نشوفه بشكل مختلف
والدليل انه بسرعه انتقلنا من احتمال انه
تحصل كارثه اليوم الحديث من فجر اليوم
يعني انه تقريبا تم حل المشكله
يمكن ان تقدم لنا قراءه اقتصاديه سريعه
ومبسطه عن الاسباب التي ادت لانهيار ه ذين
البنكين ايضا
على تحديدا انه
المشكله المشكله انه بيتعامل بشكل كبير
جدا هو البنك المفضل لشركات القطاعه
الشركات الناشئه والاستثمار الجدي وما الى
ذلك فكان بيحصل على اذاعات كبيره منهم
سواء عندما يحصلوا على التمويل او من خلال
ارباحهم
والاستثمارات اللي كان عم بيعملها كان عم
يعملها بسندات الخزينه الامريكيه اللي هي
مضمونه ولكن على فترات بعيده بفائزه قليله
لما بدات ترتفع اسعار الفائده اصبحت قيمه
السندات اللي عنده اقل لانه صار بالسوء في
سندات جاذبه اكثر ومع شح التمويل للشركات
الناشئه اصبحت تسحب منه فاصبح هناك اللي
بنسميه مس ماتش بفترات استحقاق الودائع
مقابل الاصول يعني الاصول مقابل
الالتزامات فاصبح بحاجه الى تمويل جديد
طيب لكن هناك ما يشبه التناقض ربما في
تصريحات في الداخل الامريكيه الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يتحدث عن امكانيه
استرداد الاموال بنسبه للمذيعين لكن
المؤسسه الفيدراليه الودائع اعلنت ان
اعاده هذه الاموال تعتمد على نتائج بيع
اسهم هذا البنك وبالتالي يمكن لوضعين لكن
هذا ايضا
نتائجه غير مضمونه حتى هذه اللحظه هل هناك
تناقض في التصريحات حول التعاطي مع هذه
الازمه في تقديرك
لا هو مش تناقض هو لانه يعني اصبح في عده
جهات داخله بالموضوع
جهات تامين الودائع عم تضمن الى حد معين
تم استخدام او يعني العمل على على الوصول
الى تامين اخر من صناديق اخرى موجوده
للطوارئ مع التسديد دائما انه يستخدموا
اموال دفع الضرائب اللي هي اموال عند
الحكومه يعني وايضا انه ما يكون في انقاذ
للمساهمين او للبنك نفسه بس على ضمان
الوضع لا اعتقد اعتقد يعني الجهود عم
تحاول تتكامل وحتى الان يبدو انها ناجحه
ولكن القلق انه يعني تخرج اشياء اخرى بعد
مش ظاهره حاليا او بنوك اخرى تتعرض الى
نفس المشاكل
الوقت لكن المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه خروف كما اتبعنا قبل قليل تتحدث
عن ان من ضمن الحلول التي ستلجا اليها
الولايات المتحده هي طباعه العمله بكميات
كبيره وهذا ما سيؤثر سلبا على الاقتصاد
العالمي هل تعتقد ان ذلك من ضمن الحلول
المطروحه وال تي يمكن ان تكون ناجحه مع
العكس تماما
لا لا اعتقد انه بشكل مباشر يعني انه
عمليه طباعه عمله وتغطيه التزمات ممنوع
لانه هيكليه الاقتصاد هيكليه المصارف
والنظام المصرفي من المهم جدا في امريكا
انه يكون يعني محافظ على متانته اعتقد
يعني تصريحات مثل هذه حاليا في ظل
التجربات السياسيه يعني اكثر على موضوع
يعني اتهامات عامه اكثر من انه فعلا تقنيه
او اقتصاديه لا اعتقد انه الامور تسير
بهذا الاتجاه ما هي فرص انتقال عدو
سيليكون فاليو الى بقيه البنوك الامريكيه
وخارج الولايات المتحده ايضا وماذا عن
بنوكنا في الشرق الاوسط
فرص انه تنتقل العدوى الى بنوك اخرى يعتمد
على لاي درجه المذيعين بشكل عام عم يقراوا
بقرارات الحكومه الامريكيه الاداره
الامريكيه طمئنه اذا كان في عدم ثقه يعني
انا هلا مثلا كموده حتى لو سمعت انه
الاداره عم تضمر بس بفضل انه اسحب اموالي
من بيت معين الى بنك اكبر لانه بشعر بثقه
اكبر معناتها الثقه منها موجوده كتير ممكن
نرى مشاكل اخرى هلا الانتقال العدوى الى
خارج بريط خارج امريكا بريطانيا مثلا
اشتروا البنك
نفس الشرق الاوسط لا اعتقد حسب المعلومات
المتوفره انه الانكشاف بشكل كامل على
بنوك من هالنوع موجود اعتقد انه يعني
الوضع اقل خطوره يعني طيب هل ستدفع هذه
الاحداث نحو اعاده النظر حول ما يروج له
من
صلابه النظام المصرفي الامريكي وبالتالي
وضع هذا النظام في خانه الهشاشه في تقديرك
لا اعتقد
الحديث عن موضوع هشاشه يعني كبيره جدا
حاليا يعني ولكن اعتقد قد يعاد النظر في
السياسات النقديه الحاليه اللي بخصوص رفع
الفوائد والتضخم اللي الطريقه اللي عم
بحاولوا يتعاملوا فيها قد نشهد في الفتره
القادمه وهذا ايضا قد يغير من منظور الثقه
في النظام المصري في بس يعني اعتقد في
الايام القادمه ببين عنا قدره الاداره
الامريكيه بجنحه المختلفه على السيطره على
حدث من هالنوع بشكل سريع والاستمرار او
انه حيطلع مشاكل اخرى ممكن بعدين نحكي عن
هالشاشه او ما شابه نعم شكرا لك من دبي
كنت معنا المحلل الاقتصادي احمد الخطيب
معكم هذه الاخبار العاجله التي ظهرت على
شاشه العربيه قبل قليل نقله عن الخارجيه
الايرانيه التي قالت ان الاجواء الايجابيه
للعلاقات مع السعوديه ستكون سببا لحل
الازمه وسنعلن قريبا عن مكان عقد اجتماع
بين وزيري الخارجيه السعودي والايراني
اخرج الايراني مشاهدين ايضا قالت انه
واشنطن وافقت في مرحله ما على فصل تبادل
السجناء لملف النووي ولدينا اتفاق مكتوب
مع واشنطن حول تبادل السجناء لكن نمتنع عن
نشر تفاصيله ونتوقع ان تؤثر العلاقات
الايجابيه مع السعوديه على بقيه دول
المنطقه
اذا مشاهدينا بالعوده الى سياقنا اكد قائد
القوات البريه الاوكراني الجنر الاوكسندر
ان الوضع حول مدينه باخوت لا يزال صعبا
وقال في تصريحات الصحفيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه مستمره في التصدي للمحاولات
الروسيه التي تهدف لسيطره على المدينه من
جهه اخرى اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
واشارت الى ان القوات الروسيه تحاول
اختراق الدفاع
هذا هو اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني ان اكثر من
خلال اقل من اسبوع في المعارك قرب بحموت
وحدها كما اكد الرئيس الاوكراني في خطابه
اليومي اصابه نحو 1500 جندي روسي بجروح
بالغه بما يكفي لابعادهم عن اي عمليات
اخرى
مشاهدينا الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك محمد
وبدايه اخذ الثورات المتوفره لديك حول
الوضع في باخموت ووضع القوات الاوكرانيه
ما اذا كانت فقط متواجده في خانه الدفاع
ام انها بدات تهاجم ايضا بعد الحديث عن
انها
تتحضر منذ مده لهجوم كاسحه للقوات الروسيه
في المنطقه
نعم صباح الخير يعني بعد الزيارات
المتكرره لقائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الكسندر الى منطقه ضخمه وهو يعني في هذه
الاثناء ايضا متواجد في بلده التي تقع غرب
مدينه وهو يقود عمليات الدفاع لان الجيش
الاوكراني حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال في
عمليه دفاع وكما قال سيركس لان القوات
الروسيه ومجموعات تحاول اقتحام مدينه من
كل الجهه من ثلاثه الجهات من الجهه
الشماليه التي تكثفت بالامس محاولات
الاقتحام اكثر من 61 محاوله اقتحام وهجوم
على تلك البلده على مدينه
القوات الاوكرانيه الجيش الاوكراني اعلن
انه ايضا حقق اصابات كبيره في مجموعات
فاجنر من التي تهاجم التي اصبحت متمركزه
في الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه ويفصل بين
الاحياء الشرقيه ووسط ضخم طوال الاحياء
الاخرى هو نهر ضخمه الذي اصبح كخط دفاع
اول الجيش الاوكراني من يعني بسبب هذا
النهر وبعد تدمير الجسور التي تقع على هذا
النهر اصبحت يعني الى حد ما صعوبه من
الهجوم من الجهه
الشرقيه لذلك تستعين عن الهجوم من الجهه
الجنوبيه والجهه
الشماليه القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا استمرت
بتبديل الوحدات بسحب وحدات من باقوى
وادخال وحدات اخرى لاعاده ضخم جديد في
العمليات الدفاعيه لمدينه يعني كما اصبح
واضح ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا تزال متمسكه
بهذا الموقع لكن ما هي طبيعه هذه القوات
المدافعه الاوكرانيه هناك من يتحدث عن
انهم نعم انه من قوات النخبه لكن هناك من
يقول انهم من قوات الاحتياط الاقل تدريبا
وجاهزي ايضا
يعني القوات الاوكرانيه يعني لم اسمع
سؤالك من الصوت كان يعني متقطع ولكن ما
استطيع ان اقول ان القوات الاوكرانيه التي
تدافع الان في مدينه من القوات التي بدات
تصل الى مدينه القوات التي خضعت لي
تدريبات خاصه في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وايضا لا ننسى عن بدء وصول يجب الذكر يعني
معلومه مهمه وبدء وصول عتاد غربي
وقذائف لمدافع هو 155 بدات اوكرانيا تحصل
على هذه الاسلحه التي ارسلتها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والشركاء الغربيين لذلك
يعني الخطه التي يتبعها الجيش الاوكراني
الان هو استفاده الوقت ومحاوله استنزاف
القوه الضاربه للجيش الروسي التي تتمثل في
مجموعتين هي مجموعه فادني والكتيبه
الشيشانيه التي تم نقلها من زكاروجيا
باتجاه ايضا مدينه بخموت للمشاركه في
الهجوم من الناحيه الجنوبيه وبالامس يعني
كان هناك عدد كبير من القتلى في القوات
الروسيه كما اعلن اكثر من 400 قتيل 350
الى 400 قتيل تم اعين اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني انه قتلهم في محور ضخمه بالكامل
الذي يقع من ثلاثه جهه من الجهه يعني
الشرقيه من الجهه الشماليه والشرقيه
والجنوبيه بينما الجيش الاوكراني بدا ايضا
يكثر ضرباته المدفعيه وفي الامس يعني تم
نقل العدد من منظومات جراد ومدافع هاوتر
الى المنطقه الجنوبيه لمدينه
تخفيف الضغط عن القوات الاوكرانيه
المدافعه يعني معركه ضخمه شهرها الثامن
وسلطات الاوكرانيه على الدفاع والاستماع
في دفاع عن هذه المدينه لكن هل تؤثر هذه
المعركه على بقيه المناطق في اوكرانيا او
بقيه العمليات او الجبهات في اوكرانيا
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه جيش الروسي وسع
عملياته باتجاه مقاطعه وهو كان يقوم يعني
بهجوم على منطقه التي حررتها القوات
الاوكرانيه في الفتره الماضيه ولكن بالامس
وقبل امس كانت تقريبا معظم الجبهات هادئه
نسبيا يعني هو مشتعله ولكن اهدا من معركه
وايضا لا ننسى الهجوم الذي يقوم به الجيش
الروسي على منطقه
لاحتلال تلك المنطقه لابعاد الجيش
الاوكراني والمدفعيه الاوكرانيه التي
تستطيع ضرب يعني
نقاط ومراكز داخل
منطقه هي تبعت فقط 10 كيلو مترات الى 12
كيلو متر عن مداخل مدينه تونس هناك ايضا
هجوم في منطقه زفروشيا كان يعني على
اوهلادار هذه المنطقه التي تتعرض ايضا
لهجوم كبير لذلك وضع الجبهات يعني مشتعل
ولكن اخف حماوه من وضع ضخمه لان القوات
الروسيه تضع كل ثقلها وخاصه يعني مجموعه
فاغنر الاستباق الامور والدخول والسيطره
على مدينه ضخمه لتحقيق نصر معنوي كبير
بوجه ليس بوجه اوكرانيا بل بوجهه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وهذا هو حديث سهل اعلام
الاوكرانيه عن الصراع القائم الان بين
وحدات بين قياده الدفاع الروسيه شكرا لك
كنت معنا الصحفي محمد البابا تحياتي محمد
شكرا شكرا تحياتي
الاحتياجات الايرانيه العثور على جثه ناشط
في حقوق الطفل بعد 18 يوما من اعتقاله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في ايران اعلنت
منظمه حقوق الانسان هانجهاو العثور على
جثه ناشط في مجال حقوق الطفل صادق في احد
شوارع مدينه كتسران وذلك بعد مرور 18 يوم
على اعتقاله من قبل مخابرات الحرس الثوري
الايراني كما اضافت المنظمه انه راديوند
قتل تحت التعذيب الشديد على حد وصفها
في افغانستان قال وزير التعليم العالي
بحكومه طالبان لدى محمد نديم انه يجب قتل
كل من يخالف الحكومه واضاف التصريحات التي
لقت سخطا كبيرا من شخصيات داخل الحركه
عفوا اضاف ان من يزعزع النظام بالنطق او
القلم او الافعال يجب قتله
[موسيقى]
كل من يسعى لزعزعه استقرار النظام ان كان
بالنطق او القلم او الافعال فان جميع
هؤلاء يعتبرون من البغات ويجب قتلهم
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا
دعا الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مجلس نواب
الشعب الجديد الى عقيسته افتتاحيه اليوم
الاثنين وذلك وفق امر رئاسي نشره الجريده
الرسميه حيث ان الدستور التونسيه ينص على
ضروره دعوه الرئيس انعقاد البرلمان بعد
اسبوعين من تصريح هيئه الانتخابات
بالنتائج النهائيه للتشريعيه التشريعيه
هذا وكانت هيئه الانتخابات اعلنت في 25 من
فبراير الماضي عن فوز 154 مترشحا بمقاعد
في البرلمان بعد تنظيم جولتين ويتكون
البرلمان الجديد من 161 عضوا لكنه سينطلق
في اعماله منقوصا من سبعه نواب على خلفيه
عدم تسييرات في عدد من الدوائر الانتخابيه
خارج البلاد
مشاهدينا من تونس انضموا الينا الصحفي
نسيم حمداوي اهلا بك نسرين وكيف تبدو
اجواء ما قبل انعقاد الجسر الاولى
للبرلمان التونسي الجديده وما الذي يدور
خلف الكواليس
نعم صباح الخير دقائق قليله تفصلنا عن
موعد الجلسه الافتتاحيه هنا في باردو في
مقر مجلس نواب الشعب على اجراء تبدو عاديه
باعتبار ان هنالك تواجد امني مكثف على طول
الطريق المؤديه الى هنا ساحه باردو قربه
العاصمه تونس هنالك تواجد ايضا لعديد من
وسائل الاعلام المحليه والدوليه التي تغطي
هذا الحدث الهاب الذي كان هنالك تيره اشهر
طويله كان العمل على هذا المجلس النواب
بعد انتخاب اعضائه اعضائه في السابع عشر
من ديسمبر الماضي وبعد انتفاء كل الشروط
القانونيه من الطعون وغيرها ثم اخيرا قام
رئيس الجمهوريه بدعوه مجلس النواب
الانعقاد اليوم الاثنين الثالث عشر من شهر
مارس وفقا للترتيب التي اعلن عنها مجلس
نواب الامس فان هذه الجلسه ستكون برئاسه
اكبر النواب سنا وبمساعده اصغرهم واصغرهن
سيقوم النواب بصفه جماعيه بتلاوه القسم ثم
اختيار لجنه للسهر على فرز والاعداد
الترشحات لرئاسه مجلس نواب الشعب بصفه
دائمه ثم ستقوم بتلقي الترشحات وفرزها على
دورتين اذا لم يترسح يتحصل عفوا من
المترشحين على اغلبيه الاصوات ستكون
التنافس المحموم على رئه البرلمان لكن من
هم ابرز المرشحين والاوفر حظا بينهم ايضا
لتسمعين النسرين
بالفعل هنالك عديد الاسماك التي تم
تداولها خلال الاسابيع الماضيه خاصه بعد
الاعلان عن نتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
التشريعيه لكن الاقرب من الاسماء
المتداوله هو عميد المحامين السابق
ابراهيم بودرباله باعتباره اعلن انه ينوي
اترشح الى هذا المنصب وايضا هنالك عديد
الاسماء ربما تكون من حركه الشعب التي
تحظى بنصيب وافر من اعداد البرلمانيين
الذين فازوا في هذه الانتخابات لكن الى حد
هذه اللحظه لا نعلم عدد المترشحين او من
هم باعتبار ان الجلسه لم تنطلق بان ايضا
الترشح سيكون علنيا ولكن الانتخاب هو ما
سيكون سريا خلال هذه الجلسه الاولى
الافتتاحيه هل من مواقف سجلت من قبل
المعارضه اذا هذا الحدث الهام وهل من
دعوات لتحركات احتجاجيه على سبيل المثال
في هذا اليوم ايضا
حقيقه المعارضه لم تقم باي دعوه للتحرك او
الاحتجاج خلال هذا اليوم ايضا هي لم تصدر
اي موقف لي دعوه المجلس للاناقات باعتبار
ان هذا التاريخ هو حتمي باعتبار سيروره
رزنامه التي كان اعلن عنه منذ اشهر طويله
فانه بعد الطعون سيتم بالتالي بصفه اليه
دعوه مجلس النواب للانعقاد لكن المعارضه
الى حد هذه اللحظه لم تصدر اي بيانات او
تدعو للاحتجاج بالشارع وبالتالي الامور
هنا في ساحه باردو تصير بصفه طبيعيه جدا
وبشكل هادئ نعم شكرا لك من تونس كنت معنا
الصحفيين الصين حمداوي تحياتنا وسنكون معك
في متابعه للتفاصيل هذا الحدث
وفي اعقاب اعلان السعوديه وايران استئناف
العلاقات واعاده فتح السفارتين خلال
الشهرين اكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان هذا الاتفاق لا
يعني حل كل الخلافات بين الطرفين موضحا ان
الاتفاق على العوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
يؤكد الرغبه المشتركه لدى الجانبين بحل
الخلافات عبر التواصل والحوار كما اشر
امير فيصل بن فرحان في مقابله مع الشرق
الاوسط الا انه يتطلع الى لقاء نظيره
الايراني قريبا بناء على ما تم الاتفاق
عليه مؤكدا ان الرياض ماضيه في مسار
التهدئه وخفض التصعيد استشعارا لدورها
ومسؤولياتها في تعزيز الامن والاستقرار
الاقليمي
اشارت تقديرات نشرت في تقرير لمجلس الامن
الدولي ان تنظيم داعش في العراق لا يزال
يحتفظ بنحو 400 الى 500 مقاتل نشط وفي حين
اعلن العراق الانتصار على التنظيم المتشدد
في 2017 لا يزال عناصره ينشطون في مناطق
الريفيه ونائيه في البلاد ويشنون هجمات
متفرقه على القوات الامنيه وعلى المدنيين
كذلك
[موسيقى]
نشاط مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
حفل اوسكار 2023 يستعيد بريقه ثلاث جوائز
لفيلم الماني والهند تدخل التاريخ باغنيه
مساء امريكيه لتجنب عدوى
وروسيا تحذر من ازمه عالميه
القوات الروسيه تحاول اختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه في باخموت وكييف تقر بصعوبه
الوضع
بعد 17 عاما داخل سجن اسرائيلي اكبر
الاسرى الفلسطينيين على موعد مع الحريه
اليوم
يه باطلاق صاروخي باطلاق صاروخي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعتقلت القوات
الاسرائيليه 13 فلسطينيا من مناطق متفرقه
في الضفه الغربيه والقدس من جهه اخرى ذكرت
وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه انا مواجهات
اندلعت بين فلسطينيين والقوات الاسرائيليه
في بلد علي غرباء رام الله واصيب العشرات
باختناق جراء اطلاق قنابل غاز الكفيف
باتجاههم
هذا واعلن حداد واضراب تجاري في مدينه
نابلس عقب مقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين برصاص
الجيش الاسرائيلي واصابه اخر تم اعتقاله
لاحقا الجيش الاسرائيلي وصف العمليه
بالحازمه والدقيقه باستهدافه لمن قال انهم
اطلقوا النار على موقع للجيش فيما تبنت
مجموعه عاريين الاسود الهجوم المسلح
واعلنت مقتل ثلاثه من افرادها هنا قتلت
اسرائيل ثلاثه فلسطينيين واعتقلت رابعا في
عمليه قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الفلسطينيين الاربعه اطلقوا النار على
نقطه للجيش الاسرائيلي صباحا فقتل ثلاثه
منهم واصيب رابع تم اعتقاله لاحقا وبحسب
المصادر الفلسطينيه فان الاربعه ينتمون
الى تنظيم عرين الاسود في مدينه نابلس
وكانوا في طريقهم لاطلاق النار على نقطه
عسكريه اسرائيليه بين قريتي جيت وصاره غرب
نابلس مشهد بات يتكرر يوميا تقريبا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه حداد واضراب يشل
الحركه التجاريه في المدن الفلسطينيه عقب
مقتل فلسطينيين فقد قتل منذ بدايه العام
الحالي برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من
ثمانين فلسطينيه
من مدينه نابلس شمال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
خالد القاسم العربي
اضافه الغربيه يترقب الفلسطينيون ان تفرج
اسرائيل اليوم الاثنين عن اكبر الاسرى
فلسطيني عمرا وهو الاسير فؤاد الشوبكي
البالغ من العمر 83 عاما بعد ان امضى 17
عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه حيث سيتم
الافراج عنه من سجن عسقلان وسيكون هناك
استقبال احتفالي له في رام الله هذا يعد
اسير الشوبكى سياسيا وعسكريا برتبه لواء
واحد اعضاء حركه فتح اختطفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي من سجن اريحا عام 2006 مع امين
عام الجبهه الشعبيه احمد سعد
من رام الله مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسله
عربيه خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وهل تاكد
موعد الافراج عن الاسير الشوبكي وكيف تبدو
الاستعدادات الاحتفاليه به في رام الله
لا تاكيدات حول الساعه قبل دقيقتين كنت
اتحدث مع نجله الاكبر الذي يتنقل ما بين
معبر الظاهريه
لتضارب الانباء الوارده من اداره مصلحه
السجون الاسرائيليه حول مكان اطلاق سراح
فؤاد الشوبكي او الساعه الدقيقه لاطلاق
سراحه وهذا ما اعتاد عليه الفلسطينيون
عند اطلاق سراح شخصيات
سياسيه او اعتباريه فلسطينيه يكون هناك
تمويه في المكان والموعد اما بالنسبه
للاستعدادات فسيتم استقبال الاسير او كما
اصطلح على تسميته شيخ الاسرى في هذا
المركز الترويح التابع لبلديه رام الله
بعد ان يضع اقليلا من الزهور على ضريح
الرئيس الراحل ياسر عرفات وهناك عده
فعاليات احتفاليه تنتظره فور وصوله مدينه
رام الله طيب خالد ماذا نعرف ايضا عن
شخصيه الشوبكي اسباب اعتقاله في 2006
ومكانته ايضا او ما اذا كان يرمز او له
رمزيه بين جميع الاسرى الفلسطينيين في
السجون الاسرائيليه
يعني ما نعرفه عن فؤاد الشوبكي انه من
مواليد قطاع غزه عام 1940 انهى بكالوريوس
المحاسبه من جامعه القاهره وان التحق
بصفوف الثوره الفلسطينيه منذ بدايه
انطلاقتها وتنقل مع حركه فتح بين العواصم
بين دمشق والاردن وتونس وبيروت حتى عاد
ضمن اتفاق اوسلو عام
1995 ليسلمه الرئيس
الراحل ياسر عرفات المسؤوليه الماليه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل تتهمه بتمويل
كل الاعمال غير القانونيه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه اتهمته اسرائيل عام
2002 بتمويل
شحن سفينه اسلحه عرفت حينها بكرن ايه
اعترضتها البحريه الاسرائيليه الطيران
الحرب الاسرائيلي في البحر الاحمر
وصادرتها واعتقلت كل طاقمها تتهم اسرائيل
بتمويلها وارسال القوارب لنقل الشحنات الى
شواطئ قطاع غزه قالت اسرائيل بان الشحنه
شحنه الاسلحه قادمه من ايران حينها ضغط
على السلطه الفلسطينيه فتم اعتقال فؤاد
الشوبكي في السجن المركزي في اريحا لمده
اربعه اعوام عام 2006 حاصرت القوات
الاسرائيليه السجن الذي كان يخضع لحراسه
بريطانيه وامريكيه وفلسطينيه وقامت
باعتقال فؤاد الشوبكي ومجموعه اخرى منها
الامين العام للجبهه الشعبيه احمد سعدات
وعدد من اعضاء خليه اتهمت باغتيال الوزير
الاسرائيلي رحب عام زئب طيب خالد يعني هل
يمكن ان يكون الافراج عن الشوبكي اليوم هو
مقدمه الافراج عن اسرى اخرين في السجون
الاسرائيليه في هذا السياق
لا حديث عن الصفقات تبادل او
بوادر حسينيه لاطلاق سراح اسرى ولكنه انهى
اللحظه الاخيره من الحكم الذي حكمته عليه
اسرائيل حيث حكم بعشرين عاما ثم حفظت الى
سبعه عشر عاما هو ليس مقدمه هو انهى
محكومته ومن هني
محكوميته في السجون الاسرائيليه يطلق
سراحه من الجدير بالذكر بان
فؤاد الشوبكي
يعانق الحريه بمرض السرطان في البروستات
امراض في المعده امراض في القدمين ارتفاع
ضغط الدم وضعف في النظر شكرا لكم رام الله
كنت معنا مراسل العربيه خالد القاسم
تحياتي خالد
في خطابه الاول بعد انتخابه لولايه ثالثه
مدتها خمس سنوات على راس الصين شدد الرئيس
الصيني على ضروره التعزيز الامن القومي في
كلمه القاها في ختام الدوره السنويه
البرلمان محذرا من المخاطر التي تتعارض
لها بلاده وقال نحو ثلاثه الاف نائب
تجمعوا في قصر الشعب في بكين قال ان الامن
هو اساس التنميه في حين ان الاستقرار شرط
اساسي للازدهار مؤكدا ضروره التعزيز
الكامل لعمليه تحديث الدفاع الوطني
والقوات المسلحه وجعل الجيش سورا فولابيا
عظيما يحمي سياده الوطنيه والامن ومصالح
التنميه على حد وصفه كما اتخذ زعيم الصيني
القوه الخارجيه التي تتدخل في تايوان
ان التنميه في الصين تفيد العالم ولا يمكن
للصين ايضا ان تتطور بمعزل عن بقيه العالم
وفي الوقت الذي نبذل فيه جهودا ملموسه
لتعزيز الانفتاح فاننا لن نزيد الاسواق
والموارد العالميه من اجل تنميهنا الخاصه
فحسب بل سنعمل ايضا على تعزيز تنميه
العالم باسره وسنكرس جهودنا للسلام
والتنميه والتعاون والمنفعه المتبادله
ونقف بحزم على الجانب الصحيح من التاريخ
ونمارس التعدديه الحقيقيه
واكد رئيس الصين على ان بلاده ستعمل على
تعزيز امنها القومي للحفاظ على استقارها
مشددا على ان بكين ستمضي قدما في حملتها
لتعبئه وستؤسس جيشا قويا ليحمي امنها
ومصالحها
الامن هو اساس التنميه والاستقرار هو
الشرط الاساسي للازدهار وعلينا تنفيذ نهج
شامل للامن القومي وتحسين نظام الامن
القومي لدينا وتعزيز قدرتنا على حمايه
الامن القومي وتعزيز اداره السلامه العامه
وكذلك تحسين نظام الحوكمه الاجتماعيه
لضمان نموذج انمائي جديد
يجب علينا المضي قدما في حملتنا للتعبئه
فيما يتعلق بالدفاع الوطني والجيش
وتحويل جيش الصين الى جدار كبير من الصلب
بعد اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صاروخ من غواصه
قبيل ساعات بموعد بدء مناورات عسكريه
مشتركه امريكيه كوريه جنوبيه واسعه النطاق
شددت هيئه الاركان المشتركه لكوريا
الجنوبيه على ان الجيش في حاله التاهب
قصوى وان وكاله المخابرات في البلاد
واكد المتحدث باسم الهيئه الكروني لسان
جون على ان وكاله المخابرات في البلاد
تعمل مع نظيرتها الامريكيه لتحليل تفاصيل
الاطلاق
بالامس اكتشف جيشنا صاروخا غير محدد اطلق
من غواصه في المياه بالقرب من كوريا
الشماليه وتعمل وكالات الاستخبارات
الكوريه الجنوبيه والامريكيه على تحليل
التفاصيل
هذا وانطلقت اكبر مناوره عسكريه مشتركه
بين جيش كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
لتحاكي تحديده النوويه التي تمثلها كوريا
الشماليه وذكرت وكاله انبائي هاب الكوريه
الجنوبيه ان مناورات الدرع الحريه لتستمر
لمده عشره ايام بالانقطاع وهي اطول فتره
على الاطلاق تجري فيها او بل تجري فيها
مناوره مشتركه بين البلدين وقال المتحدث
باسم هيئه الاركان المشتركه في كوريا
الجنوبيه الى الحليفين عازمان على تطبيق
سيناريوهات تدريب واقعيه تتعلق بالتهديدات
النوويه من قبل كوريا الشماليه
مشاهدينا اعلنا خبر السواحل الايطالي
فقدان نحو 30 مهاجرا قبالت سواحي ليبيا
خلال عمليه انقاذ من قبل سفينه شحن كانت
تبحر في المنطقه وافاد خبر السواحل في
بيان بان المركب الذي كان يقل 47 مهاجرا
انقلب فتم انقاذه 17 منهم بينما فقد نحو
30 اخرين المهاجرون الذين تم انقاذهم
نقلوا الى معطى لتقديم الرعايه الصحيه لهم
فيما لا زالت عمليات البحث مستمره عن
المفقودين تجدر الاشاره مشاهدينا الى ان
اكثر من 4000 شخص وصلوا الى ايطاليا منذ
الاربعاء الماضي في وقت تكافح فيه الحكومه
الايطاليه لسيطره على تدفق المهاجرين من
ليبيا الى اراضيها
اعلنت السلطات البيرو حاله الطوارئ في
البلاد حيث تسبب اعصار اياكو في هطول
امطار غزيره وتدمير مئات المنازل وحدوث
فيضانات كبيره في المناطق الشماليه البلاد
ادت الى مقتل سته اشخاص على الاقل
[موسيقى]
تحول الجدل الحاصل حول مشروع قانون قوارب
الهجره غير النظاميه في بريطانيا من
مناقشه لمضمون القانون الى خلافات شكليه
تناولت تعابير اعلاميه واسقاطات تاريخيه
فتغريده الذي يقدم برامج على قناه بي بي
سي والتي شبه فيها قانون الهجره بتلك خلال
ايام المانيا النازيه فجرت معركه كانت
تطويق اليها تيارات بريطانيا المتصارعه في
البدايه اوقف جاري لينك عن تقديم برنامج
فانسحب العديد من الصحفيين من اعمالهم في
المؤسسه اشتعلت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ولا يبدو ان هناك تهدئه من داعمي الذين
هددوا بالانسحاب من المؤسسه بسبب ما
يقولون انه انتهاك لحريه التعبير
الاشاره الى المانيا النازيه امر حساس في
بريطانيا حيث اعتبرت وزيره الداخليه ان
لها حجه لاحد في تشبيه قراراتها بالنازيين
اعتقد انه من غير المقبول مقارنه مقاييسنا
التي تعتبر قانونيه ومناسبه ورحيمه
بالمانيا في الثلاثينيات
فيما اضطرت بي بي سي الى محاوله احتواء
قرارها
اود ان ارى يعود على الهواء على بي بي سي
لكن علينا ان ننتبه الى كيفيه الحفاظ على
التوازن بين الحياد وقدره الاشخاص الذين
يعملون لحسابهم الخاص على قول الاشياء عبر
الانترنت
مشروع قانون الهجره عدت الى قرارا قاسيا
لكن لم يكن متوقعا اقحام النازيه في الجدل
الحاصل
[موسيقى]
وفيما اعتبر البعض ان جاري تجاوز المقبول
في تعليقاته اعتبر اخرون ان قرار بي بي سي
قد يحد من قدره الناس على ابداء رايهم في
قرارات الحكومه من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
انطلق حفل اعلام جوائز الاوسكار الخامس
وفنون الصوره للاحتفال بافضل الاعمال
السينمائيه التي انتجت خلال العام الماضي
وقد فاز الممثل
المساعد عن دوره في فيلم
بجائزه افضل ممثله مساعده عن دورها في
الفيلم نفسه اما جائزه افضل فيلم دولي
فكانت لفيلم
للمخرج ادوارد برجر فيما كانت جائزه افضل
فيلم رسوم المتحركه من نصيب يرمو ديلتو
للمخرج المكسيكي وذهب جائزه افضل فيلم
وثائقي للفيلم لفيلم فاني الذي تدور
احداثه حول تسميم معارض الروسي الكسنافاني
في واقعه كانت تودي او كادت التودي بحياته
وفي موقف مؤثر وبكثير من الدموع خاطب
الممثل هايكوان والدته بالقول امي لقد فزت
للثوب الاوسكار وذلك خلال تسلمه جائزه
افضل ممثل مساعد خلال حفل تسليم جوائز
الاوسكار واستذكر الممثل الفيتنامي الاصل
رحلته الصعبه الى منصه التتويج التي بدات
على متنقارب كما قضى عاما كاملا في مخيم
للاجئين وضيفا انه في النهايه او بطريقه
ما انتهى الامر به على اكبر مسرح في
هوليوود وكان حلم من الصعب تصديقه
[تصفيق]
وفي ختام هذه الساعه الاخباريه نذكر بابرز
العناوين
مساء امريكيه لتجنب عدوى افلاس سيليكون
القوات الروسيه تحاول اختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه في باخموت تقر بصعوبه الوضع
بعد 17 عاما داخل سجن اسرائيلي اكبر
الاسرى الفلسطينيين على موعد مع الحريه
اليوم
يه باطلاق صاروخى تعلن حاله التاهب
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]